je suis yucca le panda et on écoute et
quelques jolies mélodies appuyez sur les
touches couleurs pour écouter des
mélodies
je veux quoi tu es le micro qui
attaquent mais morte home étape à laver
ça depuis combien de temps
oh la vache à lait obama merci
personnellement c'est que moi je pense
que ça lui pose une question peut-être
bien c'est chanter mais en fait
clairement leur récente avant l'heure
une première fois servir du champagne ça
ce film est bon d'accord encore
est-ce que tu envoies du champagne
bien que chez soi qu'on est si bien reçu
quoi trouver ça tu es couper les cheveux
par ton pote et en plus pop du champagne
sont magnifiques
pas parce qu'on dit pas mais ça reste
quand même ce coiffeur par the best
c'est un peu mon massatois moi quoi sans
avoir brillé c'est ce que je vais dire
salut je t'ai fait l'arrêt j'ai la
russie natale
je vais marquer l'arrêt plus précise qui
m'a marqué l'arrêt bon ok boma bon
matériel c'est grégory c'est seb c'est
ton mec est accordée par s demain c'est
le réveillon de la saint sylvestre
et comme tous les ans vous allez trop
boire
du coup le lendemain vous allez avoir un
mal au casque mal à la tête et une
gueule de bois d'enfer heureusement je
suis là et je vous filer mes meilleures
astuces pour ne plus subir une gueule de
bois le lendemain d'une bonne soirée
qu'est ce qui est pire
une bonne vieille gueule de bois je
pense qu'on s'est tous dit un lendemain
de cuite plus jamais ça
c'était la dernière fois plus jamais
boire et sauf que les bonnes résolutions
d'un soir en règle générale on n'arrive
jamais à l'avenir si ce matin vous vous
réveillez avec le mal au casque le
kangourou dans le crâne que vous n'en
pouvez plus il ya quelques principes de
précaution à prendre déjà commencé un
petit peu par vous raisonner sur la fin
de ce premier c'est pas la peine de
picoler comme un parent et jusqu'à
outrance jusqu'au bout de la nuit parce
que c'est ces derniers verte
les payer le plus forcément si vous
voulez buvez vous allez mettre du temps
à les digérer vont mettre du temps
restant à votre organisme et lendemain
matin vous serez forcément encore
complètement bourré ça c'est la base
ce qu'il faut faire déjà avant d'aller
se coucher s'est essayée boire un litre
d'eau avant de vous coucher
on dirait pas mais l'alcool ça
déshydrate énormément un litre d'eau
c'est la base
prenez du citrate de bétaïne ça vous
évitera les brûlures surtout ne jamais
prendre de café si vous avez un ami qui
a trop bu
ne lui donnez surtout pas de café si
vous pensez les réveiller avec ça en
réalité ça fera l'effet inverse
son corps a signé leur a beaucoup plus
vite la colle et sera encore plus bourré
et beaucoup plus vite
le café c'est complètement à proscrire
donc on s'est tous réveillés avec des
gueules de bois comme ça plus en pouvoir
d mal de casse le secret le plus
important si vous avez trop bu
c'est de boire de la flotte buvait de la
flotte
mangez buvez de la flotte buvait de la
flotte buvait de la flotte pour le mâle
de caste rien de tel qu'un bon vieux
paracétamol si comme moi la flotte s'est
pas trop votre truc leurs 28 vous pouvez
vous prendre un bon vieux cocagne a rien
de tel ça fait du bien pour ma part
c'est coca mcdo le lendemain de cuite
c'est extraordinaire ça me retape
directement c'est le quart d'heure
prévention allez-y doucement sur la
bibine si vous prenez le volant vous
picoler pas et n'oubliez pas que même si
c'est très très bon ça fait des ravages
[Musique]